so that's me in September 2019 which is
just three months before I was diagnosed
I'm speaking at an event and I look well
you wouldn't think there was anything
wrong with me in 2019 Briny was
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer she
felt relatively normal with gradual
symptoms but her different doctors told
her different things I think I saw eight
different GPS I didn't see one person
consistently I was tested for celiac
anemia thyroid I do wonder whether if
I'd seen one doctor consistently over
those five years maybe the dots would
have been joined but that didn't happen
instead briny's cancer worsened and
spread to her lymph nodes seven percent
make it to five years I had a one
percent chance of seeing my daughter
reach her 18th birthday and I was very
likely to die within about 12 weeks the
issue staff shortages according to renew
reports this has caused almost every
Cancer Center delays in treatment this
year and so around 90 percent of
Specialists are concerned the quality of
patient care is dropping a huge concern
especially when each month that goes by
increases the risk of death by 10
percent because we've not been
increasing Medical School places and
training places quickly enough We've
Ended up with this problem of not enough
doctors we know that too many young
doctors are leaving the UK to work
overseas we know that too many
experienced doctors are retiring early
and we've got to think about ways of
changing that but the government stance
is this there are more doctors nurses
and staff working in the NHS than ever
before the NHS is also seeing treating
and saving record numbers of people with
cancer but we know there is more to do
some movement but for Briny not fast
enough
for her when lives are on the line time
really is of the essence summer
Chowdhury Sky News